it was Earth Day yesterday so it seems
that we should at least talk a little
bit about the EPA the Environmental
Protection Agency right or at least in
name after all in the United States the
EPA sadly is the top agency that relates
to the goals of Earth Day even though
the current administration is actually
doing damage to the earth rather than
helping to protect it and we did have
news yesterday about the EPA we had this
Earth Day EPA miracle which is that we
learned that Scott Pruett the head of
the organization is the target of at
least 10 federal investigations we've
been covering his scandals individually
here and there but all of a sudden
there's a lot going on with this guy
who's fundamentally the epitome of the
swamp filling that Donald Trump claimed
he wasn't going to do vice is reporting
that on at least that there are at least
10 federal investigations into Scott
Pruett they focus on a wide range of
activities number one his alleged use of
taxpayer money for first-class airline
travel number two his spending on
security which seems unusually high
number three his associations with
lobbyists remember before we went on
break we had this story about Scott
Pruett getting access to some lobbyists
condo for like 50 bucks per night
unusual pay raises for his staff the EPA
alone has four investigations into
Prewitt that they've made public they've
also confirmed to Vice the existence of
a fifth investigation we then go to the
House Oversight Committee which has an
investigation going that will call
number six into that $50 a night condo
Republican Senator John Barrasso runs
the Senate Environmental Committee they
have what we're calling investigation
number seven into Pruitt's apparent use
of multiple email accounts maybe to
evade public records requests you have
the GAO the Government Accountability
Office they're doing investigation
number eight it's hard to even keep
track here also related to possible
federal violations because of that $50 a
night condo I told you about they also
have invest
number nine related to the $43,000
soundproof booth that i previously told
you about they determined that the law
was broken by spending forty three grand
on that booth and then the White House's
Office of Management and Budget has what
we're calling investigation number ten
into Scott Pruitt also over the forty
three thousand dollar soundproof booth
there could even be more investigations
that we don't know about this is like
ten Benghazi's at once except these are
possibly real and I don't know
ultimately if Pruitt is going to stay or
go clearly the guy should go although
he's likely on policy to maybe be
replaced by someone even worse possibly
someone less corrupt but the message
that is sent by allowing Scott Pruett to
stay is that it simply doesn't matter
what you do as far as the current
administration is concerned until it
becomes a PR problem for Trump and maybe
because the EPA sort of a less glamorous
agency it's not like Secretary of State
or some of these other positions it's
sort of flown under the radar and only
when it becomes an actual PR problem
will you see this White House deal with
it but what I circle back to after
reading about all the alleged wrongdoing
by Scott Pruett the real tragedy and I
mentioned this when talking about Earth
Day is the irreversible damage that's
being done to the environment I would
actually and I may be you would disagree
with me I would actually accept some
personal corruption on the behalf of the
EPA director if he were doing wonders
for the environment and what I mean is
I'm not advocating for misdeeds to be
ignored I'm not advocating for
corruption or saying it doesn't matter
or anything of the sort what I am saying
is a lot of what is being done by Scott
Pruett that's really sketchy is enabled
by the system that we have this is not a
defense but it's enabled by the
overspending sweetheart contracts to
friends a system that we have it's
enabled by Palin around with lobbyists
these are broader issues than Scott
Pruett but they're horrible no doubt
about it if at least the guy was
protecting our environment or being
tough on business pollution or take
stand with Trump on his totally abortive
environmental policy I'd be a little
less concerned about his personal
corruption corruption relative to a $50
a night condo or Palin around with
lobbyists or spending 43 thousand
dollars on a soundproof booth I wouldn't
like it
I wouldn't defend it but I would at
least be more okay with it but of course
that's not the case right American
environmental policy is once again a
worldwide laughingstock and whether
Pruett stays or goes it is very unlikely
that it's gonna get any better under the
current administration period so on that
basis what I ask you is do you would you
prefer a corrupt Scott Pruett who is
terrible for the environment or a less
corrupt replacement that is even worse
for the environment potentially because
that's basically the sort of Sophie's
Choice that I think we find ourselves
presented with here send me your
thoughts I'm on twitter at des Pakman
the show is on twitter at david pakman
show boy did a lot go on during our
vacation and we'll be talking about a
lot of it coming up today's episode is
sponsored in part by zip recruiter every
business needs great people and they
also need a better way to find them and
something better than posting your job
online and hoping the right people will
see it is zip recruiter zip recruiter
knew there was a smarter way so they
built a platform that actually finds the
right job candidates for you zip
recruiter learns what you're looking for
identifies people with the right
experience invites them to apply to your
job and these invitations have
revolutionized how you can find your
next hire and in fact 80% of employers
who post a job on zip recruiter get a
quality candidate through the site in
just one day
and zip recruiter doesn't just stop
there they will even spotlight the
strongest applications that you get so
you won't miss any great matches the
right candidates are out there
zip recruiter is how you find them
businesses of all sizes trust zip
recruiter for their hiring needs and
right now my listeners and viewers can
try zip recruiter for free
if you go to zip recruiter dot-com slash
Pakman that's zip recruiter dot-com /pa
que ma n one more time
zip recruiter dot-com slash Pakman to
try it for free